From stray coffee cups in Westeros
to Bradley Cooper's fake baby,
things don't always go as planned
when filming a TV show or movie.
There have been numerous
mistakes in the past decade
that slipped through the cracks
and made it onto the big and small screen.
Here are 18 of the biggest
blunders of the 2010s.
In 2019, HBO aired the final
season of "Game of Thrones,"
and while fans weren't exactly happy
with how everything turned
out with the rushed plot,
there was also a major gaffe
that managed to throw viewers
completely out of the fantasy.
In this scene, a coffee
cup from craft services
(no, it's technically not a Starbucks cup)
was accidentally left in the final cut.
It's clearly visible on
the table next to Daenerys,
and, as far as we know,
there were no baristas at Winterfell.
The cup was later edited out of the shot.
After the coffee-cup debacle,
no one would have expected
yet another mistake
in the final season of "Game of Thrones."
In one of the most important
and highly anticipated
scenes of the series,
the leaders of Westeros were choosing
who would take the throne.
Edmure Tully: I suppose
this is the most important
moment of our lives.
Narrator: Unfortunately,
someone on the cast or crew
left some water bottles
in a few of the shots,
turning the serious moment
into a bit of a joke.
There's a heartwarming
moment in "American Sniper"
that quickly turns laughable.
In this scene, Bradley
Cooper has returned from war
and is picking up his child.
But since director Clint Eastwood thought
using a real baby would
be too unpredictable,
they decided to use a doll instead.
And it's painfully obvious,
especially when Cooper is seen
moving the baby's arm with his finger.
The events in season
five of "Breaking Bad"
are set in 2009 and 2010,
but one of the characters
can apparently see into the future.
In this scene, Todd's uncle references
the raid and death of Osama bin Laden.
Jack Welker: Whacking bin
Laden wasn't this complicated.
Narrator: Which didn't actually happen
until a year later, in 2011.
In "The Dark Knight Rises,"
the sun seemingly sets super early.
The stock market heist scene takes place
soon after the opening bell,
and it's clearly light outside.
But soon after, there's a car chase,
and when they all emerge from
the tunnel, it's pitch black.
Dark "night" rises, indeed.
But that wasn't the only
mistake in the film.
Typos happen all the time,
but the copy editor at The Gotham Times
probably lost their job over this one.
In the main headline on the front page,
heist is spelled wrong.
In this scene, Rachel McAdams' character
is writing down notes
from her conversation
with one of the abuse victims at a diner.
The camera cuts to the
notebook several times,
and while she seems to fill up the page,
a few shots later it's nearly blank.
Maybe it's disappearing ink?
During the final battle
scene in "The Avengers,"
there's a lot going on,
so it's not that surprising
that there would be
a few continuity errors here.
In this scene, the front of a car
is clearly dented and beaten up,
but after Thor lands on the ground,
the car has miraculously
turned to perfect condition.
A blessing from the gods.
There's another continuity
error in the final battle.
Here, we see Captain America
is shot in the stomach,
and his suit is torn and damaged.
A few minutes later, however,
it's back to normal.
Guess Captain America is also
a pretty good seamstress.
Elsa belting out "Let it Go"
is one of the more memorable
scenes in "Frozen,"
but no matter how many
times you've watched it,
you may not have noticed this
one pretty bizarre error.
In this scene, after
she lets down her hair,
she swings around and her braid appears
to magically pass right through her arm.
"Suicide Squad" wasn't exactly flawless,
but there was one scene in the film
that makes absolutely no sense.
In this scene, the characters
are all putting on their costumes,
but Harley Quinn's transformation
is a bit more drastic than the others'.
Somehow, she manages to get
a haircut and dye her hair
seconds after she puts on her outfit.
Rick Flag: Seriously, what the
h---'s wrong with you people?
Narrator: While technically
not in the show,
this promotional image for "Downton Abbey"
made headlines for something
fans spotted in the background.
Can you find it?
Yes, like "Game of Thrones,"
there's a plastic water
bottle in the shot,
sitting right there on the mantle.
You may have been too teary-eyed
at the sight of all
the Avengers assembling
to notice this one.
In this scene, we clearly see Thanos
destroy Captain America's shield.
It's cracked in half.
But soon after,
when the camera pans out
at the portals opening,
the shield is back to its original state.
If only we could snap our fingers
and do the same for Iron Man.
Henry Cavill is known as Superman,
but he appears to also have superpowers
in his role as agent August Walker
in "Mission: Impossible - Fallout."
In this scene, Cavill's beard
quickly grows while he's punching.
As if that wasn't bad enough,
a pocket also appears on his dress shirt.
In the world of "The Walking Dead,"
physics apparently don't apply.
In season five, Daryl and
Carol are trapped in a van
that's teetering on the
edge of an overpass.
Eventually, the van
falls and flips forward,
but somehow, it lands on
its wheels seconds later.
Before the coffee cup and water bottle,
there was another error
in "Game of Thrones"
that had people scratching their heads.
In season six, we learned Melisandre
turns into an old woman when
she takes off her necklace,
but in season four, there's a
scene with her in a bathtub,
sans necklace, and yet she's
still young and beautiful.
While demogorgons and strange
young girls with telekinesis
aren't very realistic,
there's one mistake the production team
on "Stranger Things" made with the props.
Throughout season one, the kids are using
realistic TRC-214 walkie-talkies
to communicate with each other.
The only problem is that
these didn't actually exist
until about two years later, in 1985.
While there's certainly
a lot of time-hopping
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
one jump in "Spider-Man: Homecoming"
seemed to mess everything up.
The movie's supposed to be set
eight years after "The
Avengers," which was set in 2012,
hence "Homecoming" takes place in 2020,
but that doesn't line up
with the rest of the films,
like "Avengers: Infinity
War," which was set in 2018.
So the entire timeline would get shifted,
making the dates the heroes jump back to
in "Endgame" incorrect.
Director Joe Russo eventually admitted
that this "8 years later" title card
was "incorrect" during a press interview.
Narrator: Were there
any other big mistakes
you noticed in the past decade?
Let us know in the comments.